en amont du pont du prêcheur le ballet
des pelleteuses et des camions a
commencé voici le fameux chantiers coup
points demandés par la ville est mise en
oeuvre par là des halles pour une durée
de quatre mois
les travaux progresseront du plateau
sportif de la cité coquette jusqu'au gay
de morne gibouin sur un kilomètre 200 il
faudra évacuer les matériaux volcaniques
selon des plans très détaillée
l'existant le terrain naturel
en ce moment elle est comme celui là là
lorsqu'on va terrasser
on est là jusqu'au rouge tout au long de
la rivière les tranches sont en cours de
signalisation
nous sommes en bon fils 22 et ici comme
s'est établi sur le petit viserait là
devant descendre de deux mètres
cinquante trois mois ce domaine 53 10 à
partir d'ici on descend et vous fait la
liaison avec un set de table
donc c'est un travail de précision c'est
pas un travail de déblaiement comme un
autre au travail mais c'est un beau
travail parce que de précision oui c'est
très impressionnant
déjà vu l'ampleur du phénomène
on est allé l'ampleur de l'ampleur du
chantier chaque jour 3000 tonnes de
matériaux doivent être évacués de la
rivière du prêcheur pour cela dix-huit
camions feront l'aller retour jusqu'aux
carrières de saint pierre jusqu'à 200
allers-retours par jour dès 8 heures du
matin dans un bourg fortement impacté
par le bruit
c'est exagéré tout ça ira mieux demain
je vais pas y est je préfère être
dérangé par les camions et puis
tranquille après quand je vais attendre
à siegen je veux dire quand même il ya
eu un gros travail qui a été fait donc
je vais pas bouger là où je suis
jusqu'en janvier les prêts chopin
doivent prendre leur mal en patience et
fermer un peu plus portes et fenêtres
d'ordinaire grande ouverte sur le bout
certains craignent à six gaz
d'échappement et poussière ça
m'interpelle parce que les camions
logiquement je les vois ressortir en
fait ils sont ni bâché et je ne voulais
pas non plus l'assurance que le sable
est mouillé en fait donc et on voit
énormément de particules qui
s'entraînent se soulever et je vous
avoue que pour ma part ça m'inquiète
énormément
l'entreprise s'engage à faire bâcher
tous les chargements de matériaux secs
en effet de 120 mille tonnes de roches
et de sable vont traverser le bourg du
prêcheur d'ici à début 2009